Apple just released the 2nd developer beta
of iPadOS, and with it comes the new SMB Server
connection feature.
With iPadOS, we’re already able to connect
everything from hard drives to flash drives
to easily access files and copy them to the
local storage.
We have a full guide on how to do that, which
you can check out by clicking the card above,
but for this video, we’re gonna show you
how to wirelessly connect to a hard drive,
NAS or server over an SMB connection.
The beauty of this is that if you love using
your iPad for editing photos or videos or
doing production work, you’ll be able to
access all of the files on your hard drive
or server as long as you’re connected to
the same WiFi connection that your router
outputs.
Modern WiFi routers allow you to connect storage
to them, either by a regular USB connection
or with an ethernet port.
The more advanced server storage systems include
ethernet ports for simple connection straight
into a router, and they also have applications
and instructions on how to connect using SMB.
The common person won’t have one of these,
they’ll have a regular hard drive, SSD or
maybe even a flash drive they want to connect
to, so let’s go through the steps on how
to do this.
First off, you’ll need to access your router's
settings through a web browser that’s connected
to your router’s WiFi network.
If you’re not sure how to do that, refer
to your router’s user manual.
Our router tells us to go to this website.
We already set it all up and created a password,
so we’ll just log in.
Now here in our dashboard, we see a section
for external storage which is empty, so let’s
go ahead and plug in a simple flash drive
into the USB port on the back.
Back at the router settings page, our drive
now shows up, so let’s click manage storage.
And right here, you can see a Mac access address
with SMB right in the beginning of it.
Now let’s go back to our iPad, go to the
Files app and tap this little edit icon within
the Browse tab.
Then tap connect to server, and type in that
SMB address and hit connect.
Now you can simply connect as a guest, but
if that doesn’t work, you can register as
a user.
Most user accounts will be named Admin by
default, and the password should be the same
password you use to log into router settings.
If not, you can read through your router’s
manual to set up your external storage and
account name and password.
We already have a large 100TB NAS with an
SMB server setup, and we’ve logged into
it on our iPad.
So here it is within the Files app, and as
you can see, we now have access to up to 100TB
of the files we use every day for editing
videos and everything else we do.
Browsing through all of the files is super
quick, no lag or load times at all.
Unfortunately, thumbnails aren’t currently
showing up, but if you tap into something
like an image, it shows up perfectly fine.
And here’s a video playing, it opens up
just fine and plays back fairly smooth but
not perfect since it’s over the internet
and not straight off a physically connected
drive.
We can easily tap and hold a file and tap
on multiple files, then open the On My iPad
location, and drop it right in.
Surprisingly, the transfer speed is very quick
considering it’s downloading the files using
WiFi, and there you have it, those files are
now on local storage.
Even better, let’s use split-view to open
up the LumaFusion video editor.
Now, we can drag and drop files straight from
the SMB server into LumaFusion, and start
editing.
This is great because if you make any changes
to files on your server on your Mac or computer,
it’ll instantly be updated on the iPad.
If we didn’t have SMB server support, we’d
have to transfer files from the server to
a flash drive, then from the flash drive to
the iPad.
This just makes it so much more convenient
to work on your iPad.
If you haven’t watched our iPadOS multitasking
guide, click you can check it out right there
and if you enjoyed this video, tap like and
hit that circle above to subscribe so you
don’t miss out on more videos like this
one.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!